can we represent a linear equation in
two variables graphically let's take a
very simple equation and try to plot it
on a graph something like X plus y
equals four it is a linear equation as
the maximum power of any variable is one
and it has two variables x and y now how
can this be represented on a graph let's
have the coordinate plane on the right
hand side it's very easy to represent
this equation graphically all we need to
do is find many pairs of x and y values
that satisfy this equation so let's make
a table here that has X values in the
first row and VY values in the second
now let's take three random values of x
say negative 1 0 and 1 and with these X
values let's see what values we get for
y if X is negative 1 then Y will be 5
because 4 minus negative 1 will give us
5 if X is 0 then Y will be 4 and if X is
1 then Y will be 3 now we got three
pairs of values which satisfy this
equation now to get the graph of this
equation we can seek to plot these
points on the coordinate plane and join
them negative 1 comma 5 will lie here 0
comma 4 will lie here and 1 comma 3 can
be plotted here now when we join these
three points we will get the graph of
this linear equation on joining these
voice we get a straight line this is the
graph of the linear equation X plus y
equals 4 it looks like a simple graph
but there are many things we can infer
from it first the graph is a straight
line the graph of a linear equation in
two variables will always be a straight
line no matter what linear equation you
pick if the graph will always be a
straight line what else does this graph
tell us another important thing it tells
us is that whichever point you picked on
this line it will be a solution to this
equation now these three points will
surely no other solutions of this linear
equation
so let's take another random point state
this one it's five comma negative one
when X is 5 and Y is negative one we see
that the equation is satisfied five plus
negative one x 4 so whichever point you
take on this line it will be a solution
to this linear equation and is there
anything else you can deduce from this
concept absolutely if we pick a point
which does not lie on the line it will
not be a solution to this equation take
any random point which does not lie on
this line say at this point negative 1
comma 2 it will not be one of the
solutions of this equation as it does
not lie on this line and we can also
verify it mathematically negative 1 plus
2 is 1 and not for now you know how to
plot the graph of a linear equation in
two variables and apart from that there
are three main takeaways from this video
first the graph of a linear equation
will always be a straight line
second every point on the line will be
the solution of the equation which
represents the line and third every
point which does not lie on the line
will not be a solution of the linear
equation which represents the line what
happens when we plot the graphs of a
pair of linear equations in two
variables we see that next
[Music]